bonjour à vous merci d'être en direct
avec nous sur l' art et france tout
d'abord quelle est l'atmosphère à bamako
en ce moment la situation calme quand
même parce qu'on n'a pas des barricades
donc la situation est normale
aujourd'hui à bamako les gens sont plus
préoccupés par la fête de l'aïd dans
cette semaine donc si on suit les mots
d'ordre de l'opposition le m5 moma des 5
juin qui a demandé la une trêve pour que
les gens puissent fêter dans la
tranquillité mais rien n'est sûr
qu'après cette fête y ont bénéficié de
cette tranquillité a beaucoup et au mali
il ya une énième tentative de la cedeao
pour sortir votre pays de la crise
politique quelles sont les chances de la
médiation ouest africaine
les cartes sont vraiment a entre les
mains des chefs d'état de la cedeao
aujourd'hui comme vous l'avez dit sont
un sommet extraordinaire visioconférence
et la semaine dernière il était à bamako
alors il était clairement vu ni pour
faire bouger les lignes
moi je me rappelle encore de la joie de
la délégation de certaines délégations
et mais a enfin ils se sont rendus
compte qu eux mêmes ils se comprennent
pas si la situation au mali le problème
de la cedao c'est un problème d'agenda
il ya beaucoup d'argent date dans un
agenda qui s'appelle agenda très mal
quand vous prenez le profil des chefs
d'état aujourd'hui les niger qui va aux
élections d'ici la fin de l'année la
coupe du var pareil et c'est des
chiffres d'état aussi qui ont des
positions et aujourd'hui il se repose
sur ce qu'on appelle si la france la
france aujourd'hui est le premier
partenaire de malice une place
économique sur le plan diplomatique sur
le plan défense donc c'était donc c'est
un acteur important non seulement au
mali mais aussi pour le sahel et donc sa
position aujourd'hui c'est une position
extrêmement importante et commencer à
l'eau tout dépendra aujourd'hui la
position du ministre malien cristallise
les débats ça a été le cas lors du huis
clos des chefs d'état ils se sont pas
compris
alors pour l'opposition m il est clair
que c'est une
l'un peut plus diriger le gouvernement
étant donné tout ce qui s'est passé avec
la tuerie déjà des manifestants la
permettre jeu de merde pour une partie
des îles parce qu il valait donc c'est
cette personne là aujourd'hui qui
cristallise aujourd'hui les débats pour
ce qui concerne l'assemblée nationale je
vous rappelle qu'il faut comprendre la
somme de la sonatt c'est un problème
interne de la majorité présidentielle
les députés aujourd'hui où la quasi
totalité des députés à part quelques-uns
qui qui auront cette difficulté ou qui
ont ce problème c'est des députés de la
majorité c'est à dire soit leur père du
président de la république ou l'adema
qui est ce on a lieu donc l'opposition
n'a pas justement quelles sont les
pistes pour sortir la crise du mali est
ce que parce que je sais que la cédéao
plaide en faveur de la formation d'un
gouvernement d'union est ce que c'est la
seule piste aujourd'hui on sait que
l'opposition demandent aussi le départ
du président ibrahim boubacar keïta
il faut comprendre d'abord pour
l'opposition à la pile de sortie de
crise
aujourd'hui c'est c'est un premier essai
la nomination d'un premier ministre
consensuel c'est la formation d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale
donc ça ce sont les ce sont vraiment les
points importants pour le m5 est bon la
cour constitutionnelle elle est dissoute
donc ça ce sont vraiment les points
c'est que la vidéo propose la vidéo
propos d'un différend à propos de la
dissolution de l'assemblée nationale il
propose un grand moment d'union
nationale mais il ne m'est inédit sera
dirigé par un premier ministre de
consensus ou pas et c'est là le problème
et c'est là le problème de l'opposition
à ce qui concerne la démission du chef
de l'état je vous rappelle que jusqu'au
dernier nouvelle c'est pas le point le
plus important pour
une grande partie du n 5 parce que du
moment où ils ont un premier ministre de
consensus un moment d'union nationale
parce qu'ils peuvent aller dans cette
année bourg pour aller vers les
élections au mali qui sont entrés en
2023 donc voilà aujourd'hui la situation
s'est de la démission du président de la
république n'est pas vraiment la chose
la plus importante où le poids le plus
important pour l'opposition
ben ahmed une question vous y avait ces
allusions c'est le rôle de la france qui
rend aujourd'hui on a justement un
soldat tombé à bamako il ya une présence
militaire française dans le sahel au
mali on sait que les enjeux sécuritaires
sont très importants c'est pour cette
raison que les membres de la cedeao
souhaite une sortie de crise assez
rapidement sur le rôle de la france que
pouvez vous nous dire concrètement nous
comme comme g20 des lapins joue un rôle
très important au mali et au sahel de
façon générale se peut que baisser les
prix mais pays appartient de malice les
plans défense ce critère sur le plan
économique mais aussi sur les plans
diplomatie au niveau de l'onu
je vous rappelle qu'il ya beaucoup de
choses qui sont soutenues par la france
non seulement pour le mali mais aussi
pour la cedeao donc elle a importants
elle a un poids important et les
sociétés françaises aujourd'hui et il
participe au niveau du mali pour pour
gagner 2 de marché pour gagner voilà
pour gagner de l'argent et donc selon
les infos que j'ai il à quel point le
ministre est favorable pour 2 contre et
cuisson très prochainement sera
notamment les contrats de quatre
l'identité nationale c'est à la fois
sécuritaire et économique etc des anges
est important il ya des sociétés
françaises qu'ils ont sont candidats
pour ce contrat là et selon maison vaut
la ministre est favorable pour les
sociétés françaises
alors c'est là que j'ai mais pour moi je
dis la position de la france elle est
très importante dans cette crise au mali
et on verra la décision de la cedeao et
comme je dis même même le président de
la cedeao qui se soient religieux ou
encore du bal ou en guinée ont des
élèves
très prochainement et dont il compte sur
la position de la france s'ils avouent
babette d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste merci à vous faut